[Applause]
meagan Marco reveals how hubby Prince
Harry inspires her in a sweet Instagram
birthday message Magic's it's pretty
amazing the Dutchess of Sussex took to
their joint account on Sunday smirking
the Dukes 35th birthday with a photo
collage highlighting different parts of
his illustrious life with nine images in
total Meghan documented everything from
baby Harry with his late mom Princess
Diana
to his first day of nursery school of
course Harry's military service is also
on full display
and what collage would be complete
without a pic from the couple's wedding
plus a family photo with their four
month old son Archie best guys in the
world the post is captioned quote
wishing a very happy birthday to His
Royal Highness Prince Harry the Duke of
Sussex it also includes this birthday
message from the Duchess of Sussex quote
your service to the causes you care so
deeply for inspires me every day you
were the best husband and most amazing
dad to our son we love you happiest
birthday I never thought my life would
be that awesome
last month Megan celebrated her 38th
birthday which Harry marked with a
special Instagram tribute of his own
calling mm his amazing wife and thanking
her for joining him on this adventure
it's also the same vein of work that my
husband and I will continue doing really
strong community based projects and this
is something that we'll be excited to be
able to share more about next year and
we launched our foundation Sussex royal
in 2020 and speaking of adventures Megan
returned from maternity leave on
Thursday to launch her smart set capsule
collection for the charities smart works
anyone play rugby no one in this group
meanwhile Harry visited with kids and
coaches at the Rugby Football Union all
schools program where he was overheard
telling a young girl that his four month
old son is doing really well thanks
adding that he's getting so big
this looks at changing every single day
next up for the Sussex is a royal tour
of Africa
Archie's going to the Africa tour is
just days away and the couple have been
very busy preparing for this and not
only is there an incredibly busy
itinerary of engagements that they're
going to be carrying out there lot of
background a lot of research and will go
into making sure that both of them are
fully prepped for this tour but of
course they're taking a five month old
baby and that entails a huge amount of
planning the current Perry has said he's
absolutely thrilled to be taking his
wife and his new son - I think a part of
the world that he considers a second
home
[Music]